The Ted Lasso welcome wagon has
arrived!
(All)
Ted!
♪♪
(Crowd noise)
(Punt)
(Crowd) -Aww.
♪♪
Lloyd:
So, you're heavily favored this
weekend?
Do you think this will
end your embarrassing streak of
draws?
Lloyd, I've never been
embarrassed about having streaks
in my drawers.
Ted:
You know, it's all part of
growing up.
♪ Pressure pushing down on me ♪
Ted:
I've got a question for you.
Has a team, guy like us, ever
won the whole chimichanga?
-Not for forty years.
Ooh!
Oh, we're coming in through
here.
-That's fine. Yeah, I got ya.
It's like Dukes of Hazzards.
-Hahaha.
Y'all probably call it the
Earls of Risk over here.
♪ It's the terror of knowing
what this world is about ♪
We've got work to do.
♪ Watching some good friends
screaming let me out ♪
I think it's time for
these young fellas to meet,
Ted:
that guy.
Oh no, Led Tasso.
♪♪
Aagh!
-(Whistle blows)
Alright you little turd-birds.
Start touching your toes.
Now touch each other's toes.
(All)
-What?
(Clap-clap)
-How long was I out?
Not as long as last time,
but nobody was hurt.
Okay.
♪ Why can't we give ourselves
one more chance ♪
People saying there's something
wrong with us.
Ted:
Not the way I see it.
I believe in Communism.
Rom-communism that is.
Ted:
If Tom Hanks and Meg Ryan,
can go through some heartfelt
struggles and still
Ted:
end up happy.
Then, so can we.
♪ Caring about ourselves ♪
Woo-hoo!
♪ This is ♪
(Growling sound)
♪o ur last dance ♪
This is our turn to make
history.
And I believe we're gonna do
just that.
♪ Last dance ♪
(All)
-Yeah!
♪ This is our last dance ♪
To the family we're born with...
Higgins:
and to families you make along
the way.
To Richmond!
♪ To ourselves ♪
♪ Under pressure ♪
Alright, let's go kick their
butts.
Butts on 3.
-Works for me.
1-2-3.
(All)
-Butts!
♪♪